and he said that when you commit to
somebody there is the inevitable pain
that any future catastrophe is going to
need to be worked out in a difficult way
between you and the person that you've
committed to as opposed to you being
able to go oh well the side chicks are
warm on Tinder in any case I'm off yeah
right well that was something I really
learned from Reading Carl Jung he used
the alchemical symbolism as purification
requires heat and pressure so you have a
container and it gets hot and that's
when you want to leave that's when the
changes can take place and sometimes
they have to be radical to maintain the
relationship but what makes you think
you'd make them if there wasn't a fire
lid under you one of the fires is I
can't escape from you here we are locked
in combat there's no out except through
and there's no evidence that through
will work and so that's part of the
utility of the bow is to turn the
temperature up and you know you could
say well I'll Escape but the problem
with that is escape to where you're not
going to have another relationship to
the degree that you brought the
catastrophe to the previous relationship
what makes you think you're not going to
bring it to the next relationship you're
the common denominator I've had many bad
relationships like really I've never met
anyone I can trust okay what's the
common denominator here